uh over the past year or so since since
purchasing X you've become more
political is there a part of you that
regrets that have I in this
battle to um sort of counter way the the
woke that comes from yeah I guess if you
consider fighting the woke mind virus
which I consider to be a civilizational
threat to be political then yes so
basically going into the the battle the
battleground of
politics is there part of you that
regress that yes I don't know if this is
necessarily sort of one candidate or
another candidate but it's um I'm
generally against things that are anti-
meritocratic uh or where there's an
attempt to suppress
discussion um where even discussing a
topic is you know not
allowed um the work B virus is communism
rebranded well I mean that said because
of that bad battle against the woke mind
virus you've perceived as being
right-wing if the woke is left then I
suppose that would be true um but I'm
not sure I think there are aspects of
the left that are that are good I mean
if you're in favor of you know the the
environment um or you know if you want
to have a positive future for Humanity
if you believe in empathy for your
fellow human beings
um you know being kind or not cruel I
whatever those values are you said that
you were previously left or Center left
what would what would you like to see in
order for you to voting for Democrats
again no I I would say that i' be
um probably left of center on social
issues probably a little bit right of
Center on economic issues and that still
holds true yes but I think that's
probably you know half the country is
isn't that maybe more maybe more are you
and AOC secretly
friends or
bigger question do you wish you and her
and just people in general of all
political Persuasions would talk more
with empathy and maybe have a little bit
more fun and Good Vibes and humor on
online um I'm always in favor of humor
that's why we have funny mode but Good
Vibes camaraderie humor you know like uh
like friendship yeah I don't well I you
know I I don't know aocf you know was um
I've only been at one I was at the the
Met when she was when she attended um
and she she was wearing this dress uh
but I can only see one side of it so it
looked like eat the itch but I I don't
know what the rest of it said yeah yeah
something not
sure tell me about the itch eat the itch
I think we should have a language model
complete what are the possible ways to
complete that sentence and so I guess
that uh that didn't work out well well
there
still I root for friendship sure sounds
good more car
realistic